تعاونا وتنافسن تقارب في زمن حرب اوكرانيا
بعد جفاء في مرحله تاريخيه ما الحلف
الروسي الصيني المبني على مواجهه حلف
الغرب بقياده الولايات المتحده يتعزز
يخاطب كل منهما الاخر بالصديق العزيز من
الرئيسين الروسي الذي مير بوتين والصيني
عن بعد سمع منه كلام يوثق تقاربا مرشحا
للتطور كلما طالت الحرب في اوكرانيا اكد
بوتين وشي على تعزيز التعاون العسكري بين
البلدين ومن اجل عالم متعدد الاقصاب
سيعملان
كده انا ينظر بنفس الطريقه لاسباب ومسار
ومنطق التحول مستمر في المشهد الجيو سياسي
العالمي وعلى الرغم من الضغوط كغربيه غير
المسبوقات تستمر الروسيه والصين في الدفاع
عن موقفهما المبدئيه
التعاون مهم جدا واهدافه متعدده
الشراكه الروسيه الصينيه
علاقاتنا وهذا ما يعكس تطور معدل التبادل
التجاري الذي بلغ مستوى 100 مليار دولار
هو واقول بصراحه اننا نمر بتحديات مختلفه
وفي ظل ظروف الصعبه يجب ان يساعد بعضنا في
التغلب على هذه التحديات
القمه الافتراضيه لبحث واقع كله رهانات
غير مسبوقه سبقتها مواقف ولقاءات مباشره
قبل ايام قليله اجرت بيت وموسكو منورات
عسكريه في بحر الصين الشرقي زادت من قلق
وغضب واشنطن وحلفائها وتبقى الصين على
الراس قائمه الاسواق البديله للنفط والغاز
الروسيين لمواجهه العقوبات الغربيه
من الغاز عبر الخطوط الانابيب وسفن الغاز
الطبيعي
لكن مع تحسينات المخطط لها ستصبح روسيا
المورد الرئيسي للغاز للصين
يتوقع الرئيس بوتين زياره نظيره شيك في
الربيع المقبل اخر لقاء بينهما كان في
سمرقند خلال القمه منظمه شنغهاي في سبتمبر
الماضي وقبلها في بيجين في فبراير الماضي
وقع حينها شركه نستراتيجيه بلا حدود اسسها
انعدام الثقه المشترك بالغرب من اوكرانيا
الى تايوان مرورا بمنطقه اسيا الوسطى ربيع
في روسيا والصين كم سيتم